Now, the question is, how can I test a function like this,
that includes this nondeterministic component?
One thing we want to be able to do is inject into here
some deterministic numbers to say this is the sequence
of "die rolls" I want to give you and then,
from that, then I can check if it's doing the right thing.
This is an example of a concept called Dependency Injection,
which has a rather scary and intimidating-sounding name,
but it's actually a pretty simple idea.
The idea is we've got a function like this, it's a big complicated function
and way down somewhere inside, there's something
that we want to affect, something we want
to monitor or track or change.
Dependency Injection says this function
depends on this random number generator,
so let's be able to inject that.
How do we inject something into a function?
Well, we just add it as an argument.
So let's add in the argument here, and let's call it "die rolls"
and say, that's going to be a sequence or
an iterable that will generate possible "die rolls.
In the normal case, that will just be random numbers exactly like it was before.
We don't care what they are, but when we want to test the function
we can inject the "die rolls" that we want.
We can just pass in a list saying what happens
if the "die rolls" are a 6 and a 1 and then a 3 and a 5, and so on.
Tell me what happens.
So here's my implementation of the Dependency Injected Play Pig.
I still have the regular arguments "A" and "B."
There's an optional argument.
If I leave that out it should behave exactly like it did before.
But if I specify it, then I have control over it.
So "die rolls" should be an iterable that generates rolls.
Here we go down and we ask for the next one
out of those rolls and get it back.
By default, "die rolls" just says we're going to generate
an infinite sequence of random integers from 1 to 6.
Oops, I think I misspoke there.
I think I said that "die rolls" have to be an iterable.
Actually, what it has to be is an iterator such as a
generator expression or something else,
in order for it to have the next apply to it.